you know all that frustration when your
computer crash is right in the middle of
a game now what you suspect is a
reasonable reaction to that may be
swearing perhaps throwing your mouse
across the room or maybe taking your
computer and shooting it repeatedly with
a gun in what is without a doubt the
dumbest games related new story i have
reported on any long time a man by the
name of lucas hench decided that the
best approached his computer repeatedly
hitting that blue screen of death was to
take his beloved machine out back and
put it out of its misery eight times
officers in Colorado Springs where the
Machine aside took place responded to
shots fired in an alley there they find
Lucas who had just blasted eight
real-life bullets into his poor computer
with a nine-millimeter handgun in the
subsequent police report which was
apparently titled man kills his computer
authorities reported that their
investigation revealed the hinge 37
became frustrated with his computer
after it kept giving him the infamous
blue screen of death Hinch was cited for
discharging a firearm within city limits
had his weapon confiscated and faces are
possible fine he wasn't arrested though
for firing the gun in public because
Colorado Springs has no laws about
machine homicide authorities told the
Los Angeles Times it was glorious hench
said of shooting and killing his
computer Adele XPS 410 apparently quote
angels song on high so would you make of
this circuit slaughter and what's the
most rage you've ever dished out on your
machine also do you think it's possible
the Hinch traveled back in time and by
shooting his computer is actually
stopped a whole load of events that
would have resulted in the rise of the
machines and the dooming of mankind let
me know in the comments and for more
probably less dumb games related news
come on back to gamespot
you